[Musica]
buonasera aspetta lo rifacciamo proprio
molto di nuovo su questo piccolo parco
buonasera a tutti
ok così va meglio mi sembra proprio un
atmosfera freestyle in circle in circle
a parte la presentazione per me è sempre
quella più difficile ogni volta che vi
presento che qualcuno si interfaccia
come chiaramente ti chiede il nome no e
io piacere swan
vedo già quella faccia tipo su anno ma
sicuramente è un nick
probabilmente non è il suo nome che
lavoro fai nella vita sua
faccio il freestyler ok a quel punto la
faccia è sempre uguale la faccia tipo di
chi va bè questo mi sta prendendo
assolutamente in giro insomma sono qui
per farvi vedere un po di calcio
freestyle ve ne parlerò dopo ma se
volete vi faccio vedere una piccola
performance di calcio freestyle
io sono pronto con lo per lo show
voi siete pronti per lo show fantastico
e te imparato subito ci siamo
[Musica]
una piccola piccola dimostrazione
so che potete fare un applauso migliore
ma non faremo più la mariam più in là lo
faremo i pirla ok da qualche parte ci
sono io da bambino chiuda bambino con un
pallone da calcio come sempre non
sembrano anch'io con un pallone a calcio
chiaramente come tutti i bambini chiuso
il fiatone avevo promesso nel stesso
guarda spero di fare l'ospizio che sono
presentati nel sommesso la camicia so
già sudato dopo due minuti oren
insomma il calcio tutti i bambini
camminano vedono un pallone e tirano i
primi calci ad un pallone tutti l'hanno
fatto e io l'ho portato un po più in là
e la prima volta che ho visto il calcio
e che mi sono innamorato del del calcio
prima che del calcio freestyle è stato
grazie a roberto baggio il mio idolo da
bambino mi hanno fatto anche un codino
per assomigliare a lui
insomma come tutti i bambini ci avevo
l'idolo che era roberto baggio è la
prima volta che ho pianto per il calcio
è stato quando roberto baggio alla
finale dei mondiali nel 94 ha sbagliato
il calcio di rigore contro il brasile
contro aspettate tapparella ecco
roberta
alto in campionato del mondo è finito lo
vince il brasile è stato la prima volta
che io mi sono emozionato per il calcio
in generale per una performance sportiva
e quindi ho iniziato a giocare a calcio
perché volevo assomigliare a roberto
baggio detto ok ora faccio esattamente
le cose che che faccio a lui non prova a
creare un po la magia all'interno di un
campo di calcio
ho iniziato a farlo io sono cresciuto
come calciatore
già gli allievi facevo i campionati
nazionali e mi sono reso conto che più
andavo avanti più il campo di calcio
diventava stretto un limite un
rettangolo all'interno del quale quello
che facevo era limitato il mister ti
diceva fa e l'ho giocata semplice invece
mi piaceva sempre uscire un po da quelli
che sono gli schemi oltre che di schemi
del calcio per l'allenamento è iniziato
il percorso da studente l'ho fatto
l'istituto d'arte volevo in qualche
maniera esprimere le mie qualità
esprimere ciò che sapevo fare anche
all'interno del del percorso di studi
quindi ho fatto un percorso di studi
artistici la parola che odiavo di più è
perché si fa così perché si fa così e la
risposta che davano i professori quando
non sapevano insegnare ma come mai si fa
come mai devo fare questa giocata perché
non posso fare questo
in questo momento posso usare questo
trick per andare no no si fa così perché
si fa così ma perché non sapendo di dare
alla risposta
chiaramente si limitavano a dire queste
semplici paroline il perché si fa così
io sia nel percorso del calcio che nel
percorso didattico sono sempre stato
curioso di sapere il motivo
non volevo subito la soluzione mi piace
di più il percorso per raggiungere
questa soluzione il perché si fa così
ora c'è una frase che ho portato che mi
piace che mi piace un sacco
una frase di picasso che impara le
regole come professionista in modo da
poterle rompere come un artista è una
frase che mi piace un sacco e
introduco questa fase questa frase il
discorso del calcio freestyle che una
disciplina sportiva ma anche artistica
sport e arte in una ricca disciplina se
le mettiamo assieme sport earth diventa
un unica parola un genio creativo l'ha
pensata si chiama sparta quello che
facciamo noi e sparta effettivamente un
incrocio tra esattamente tra sport e
arte sport perché per fare calcio
freestyle ei migliori freestyler del
mondo si allenano ore ore ora in sei ore
di allenamento al giorno e uno dice ok
ti alleni così tanto per andare magari
alle olimpiadi per diventare un
professionista assolutamente no lo fanno
per la sola passione di farlo per il
solo gusto di spingere il limite sempre
più la il limite personale
una sfida costante con te stesso arte
perché attraverso il card
il pallone è una cosa che faccio anch'io
sempre difficilmente un microfono in
mano lo faccio più spesso con un pallone
da calcio
proviamo comunicare proviamo comunicare
con il pubblico al ritmo di musica che
orografico e provando a fare queste due
cose assieme
ok ora voglio fare un esperimento non lo
sinceramente non ho mai fatto
per farvi capire un po come funziona
calciofree stelle perché si associa
viene il mondo dell'arte
immaginate un trick quindi un movimento
che si fa col corpo
immaginate come se fosse una nota
musicale tante note musicali una vicino
all'altra creano una melodia benissimo
il catcher nel calcio freestyle tanti
trick uno dietro l'altro formano delle
combo per questo calcio kristen non è
mai scontato ogni show è diverso
dall'altro perché le combinazioni che ci
sono e le variabili che ci sono durante
uno show sono talmente tante da
costringerti a reinventare il trick
sempre e nell'immediato chiudere che
possiamo che provarci ho provato a
portare una canzone vediamo se riesco a
seguire i trick andare a ritmo con la
musica
[Musica]
ok e funziona così tanti piccoli trick e
che insieme fondano combinazioni sempre
diverse a vent'anni mi trasferisco da
trieste a roma inizia mio percorso
universitario sono adatto all'isi di
roma
un'università di design iniziato un po
accantonare quello che era il calcio
perché studiavo dalle 9 di mattina alle
sei di sera e nuovo proprio tempo per
riuscire a dedicarmi al calcio giocato
così l'inizio d'allenarmi secoli amici
che sotto casa da solo per migliorare
comunque e per tenere viva quella che
era la mia passione
succede però che il mio coinquilino
sapendo che mi piaceva così tanto che sa
cosa mi scrive a mia insaputa il primo
torneo nazionale mi fa
domani si è impegnato per il motivo esce
primo campionato italiano ma non sono
assolutamente pronto non mi a roma
interfacciato con nessun altro
freestyler però avremo belli ti diverti
effettivamente da cui si mi sono
divertito
se entrato nei primi 32 mondo sono
entrato poi nei primi 16 nei primi otto
semifinale e ho perso la finale arrivato
secondo in italia per honda lì la mia
vita è stata totalmente ribaltata
giocavo in una squadra giocavo in un
team ha iniziato a lavorare col calcio
freestyle
tre giorni dopo era fare una performance
in lussemburgo
a rappresentare l'italia che su questa
italiano a loosing lussemburgo e da lì
abbiamo iniziato a fare una serie di
eventi uno dietro l'altro questo è una
foto del mio primo torneo non era più
forte tecnicamente assolutamente ancora
non conoscevo quelle che erano le skills
parole empatia con il pubblico iniziavo
a capire e avere il pubblico dalla mia
parte rispetto all'avversario questo mi
faceva vincere le sfide mi ha quasi
tutto perché la finale ero persa però
successivamente mi sono rifatta
e iniziato così bene nella frase nella
fase successiva
esci dalle regole appunto il calcio
freestyle
quindi ti permette di vedere le cose al
di là di sapere come fare una skin e di
come superare l'uomo non maniera diretta
ma avendo un ventaglio di opzioni
decisamente decisamente maggiore
nella prossima però ora esce ore
ok e da qui inizia discorso fast food
crew e il nome della mia squadra di
calcio freestyle
iniziamo a fare università iniziò a fare
calcio freestyle contemporaneamente da
una parte andavo a scuola fino
all'università finivo l'università e
scappavo a fare degli eventi di calcio
freestyle mi ricordo che durante la mia
tesi io sono tornato il giorno prima da
tanti bar in ritardo aereo ritardo
arrivo la mia tesi coi professori
mezz'ora dopo con le valigie a marzo
abbronzato e stata una situazione
drammatica mia madre non mi voleva
parlare più ma ce l'ho fatta così
insomma e se un partiti dalle basi
innanzitutto abbiamo creato una squadra
cui migliori free stare d'italia quali
sono i frentani che incarnano secondo
noi lo spirito del calcio freestyle e lo
spirito di questa disciplina e abbiamo
preso il free sterno da tutta italia non
solo da roma io sono da trieste cioè non
l'asse di qui a roma b ho iniziato a
prendere i più forti freestyler 1 st
pescara 1 a milano uno a salerno abbiamo
creato una specie di all star team di
tutti i freestyler italiani la prima
cosa era trovare un nome il nome era per
l'appunto abbiamo deciso fast food crew
un nome che dice tutto
fast food piede veloce è un nome che lo
ricordi e soprattutto io nome che deriva
da qualcosa di urban no come i fast food
e fano ritroviamo li troviamo soltanto
città e quindi abbiamo creato questa
squadra e siamo partiti dalle basi
sapevamo fare i trick sapevamo come fare
certe skills ma non sapevamo
assolutamente come si creasse uno show
di calcio freestyle venivamo tutto da
quello che era il calcio giocato non
avevamo minimamente idea di come fare e
quindi siamo partiti da via del corso
abbiamo preso il pallone andavamo via
del corso e facciamo degli spettacoli
questi spettacoli fermavamo totalmente
via del corso in questo modo in maniera
più o meno legale tutta la polizia di
roma c conoscenza infatti per questo
motivo e facciamo liscio non tanto per
imparare le skills innanzitutto a
gestire la pressione quante volte sotto
pressione ci capita di sbagliare o che
nel calcio freestyle utilizziamo uno
strumento come il pallone il pallone
rimbalza va via
abbiamo quindi di vista per gestire la
tensione molto molto molto bene e farlo
sotto casa o farlo davanti a un pubblico
c'è una di tutta la differenza del mondo
e poi imparare le pause imparare ad
avere empatia con il pubblico e imparare
come gestire per l'appunto tutte queste
cose contemporaneamente abbia iniziato
dalla strada
e la prima volta che andai in un'agenzia
chiedere ma siete interessati al calcio
freestyle perché non sviluppiamo un po
questo questo percorso perché lo
sviluppiamo il calcio frizione italia mi
dissero i caci cristiano a moda passerà
sicuramente è una moda si è come re
probabilmente no ci avrà un boom e poi
alla fine finirà lì
lo scorso anno abbiamo fatto per
l'appunto 192 date collaborando con le
squadre più forti al mondo attualmente
lavoriamo per la roma immagino che qui
ci siano diversi tifosi della roma
giusto c'è qualche tifoso più l'azione
mi sun è iniziato così un sacco di date
presentazioni dalla champions league ap
la presentazione della coppa del mondo
abbiamo fatto un sacco di eventi in giro
per il mondo e lo scorso anno mi sono
ritrovato la forma l'evento in cina mi
chiamo al milan per fare un tour per
portare la champions league che il milan
ha vinto nel 2007 in tour in cina arriva
in cina è il testimonial di questo
evento era roberto baggio allora mi
ritrovo a roberto baggio e a fare uno
show davanti a lui davanti a un sacco di
gente ma fondamentalmente la pressione e
tutte le cose che facevo tutti gli
skills che proponevo gli stavo facendo
vedere a lui no
e infine show mi chiede ma perché non
giochi con noi stasera ma ora non gioca
da un sacco di tempo non ho neanche le
sue gioca con noi stasera ti metti il
centrocampista centrale sailing c'è
dietro solo franco baresi no in difesa
quindi non è un problema io chavo lui
davanti roberto baggio dietro e la
partita andata così
tocco di varese davanti all'uomo
ho fatto il gol dell'uno a zero davanti
a roberto baggio
insomma da piccolo avevo roberto baggio
come idolo volevo diventare un
calciatore volevo diventare un
calciatore forte come lui il calciatore
non lo sono mai diventato però alla fine
sono diventato un free styler e tramite
un percorso totalmente diverso sono
diventato un compagno di squadra di
roberto baggio e questo mi ha fatto
capire una cosa fondamentalmente che da
un punto a a un punto b non c'è soltanto
una retta alle volte basta un trigger
[Applauso]
ma è che vai easybreak itecs classica
guerra per best song tecnova genova ge
tel
[Musica]
lei
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ma va p
bene male
aaron jackson
[Musica]
ieri
e adesso
[Musica]
vietti
in tre anni
capisce ma
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco chiama di tutti
ragazzi complimenti prego presenta sulla
gru
mi presento tanto lei standing ovation
quando ti abbiamo visto bravo per ultima
che si chiami per ultima per ultimare
però gioca da salerno city lo chiamano
il mago del freestyle per questo il suo
nome d'arte è omagh giuseppe cardaropoli
è appena tornato da una torre
internazionale nel quale si è
classificato terzo quindi ha
rappresentato l'italia come sempre nei
migliori dei modi direttamente da milano
davide pisa ring ci puoi dire prima
quanti anni hai
quindi ha vinto gioca con la serie a del
latina calcio ma come me ha iniziato
dirà mister preferisco fare
qualcos'altro da latina 15 anni
anastasia bagagli i grandissimi ragazzo
[Musica]